okay here we are on the internet for our
how do you combat contact conflict
fatigue and apathy among Americans for
humanitarian disasters abroad that's
something that we struggle with every
single day and I think that's one of our
main responsibilities as journalists we
have to keep going out there and trying
to figure out new in different ways to
present a story we cannot allow a sense
of futility to silence us
or to stop us and frankly for us combat
fatigue is not a luxury that we have we
cannot stop we cannot stop fighting for
these basic humanitarian principles for
children that are dying for people that
are starving because if we stop fighting
for that then what kind of a world do we
live in but also take on the lie that
the aid makes no difference because
that's the biggest lie of all actually
if you go and see what does the
education do what does the health do it
makes a huge difference and the biggest
lie is that American aid is making a
difference tool okay Debbie what do you
think of sorry sorry would I not make it
not only for her sorry for everybody I'm
through here please
if anyone's rude here at table you know
it's always a jump ball what do you
think of Theresa may calling for a snap
election it's a sign of her strength
because she's 20 percent ahead in the
polls but it's also a sign that in six
months time the economy is going to be
down and these European negotiations are
going to be nasty brutish and long but
the Jeremy Corbyn is that the labor guy
in Britain he's sane full for you to say
that yes that is the that is the leader
of the party moment and mean man I
thought we had some care leaders
this guy is too far right I mean we're
all liberals here but looks like you are
you know you okay yeah you you're an
atheist you play one on TV I'm bouncing
I see what do you think of conservative
media outlet the blaze that's Glenn
Beck's old organization yes finally
firing Tommy Laurence she was on our
show she's a trump supporter because of
her views on abortion yeah yeah I mean
there's some there's some censorship on
the right also there she said she was
okay with abortion and boy they got rid
of her like that yeah I don't know what
was behind that you know the this palace
intrigue within the blaze and why that
decision was made they're saying that it
didn't it wasn't her position that was
problematic it's that she changed it but
I don't know it sounds like a whole lot
of cat fighting isn't he okay can
everyone go to work in there do their
job okay congressman how do veterans
fare under Trump's proposed budget
because he talked a lot about how much
he loves veterans and he's not the kind
of guy to just talk out of that
absolutely
terribly terribly in time he wants to
get rid of the VA he wants to get out of
the State Department we all know look I
want to get ridden want to get rid of
the VA well that's what he said during
the campaign he said everybody should
just go to private health care
facilities that will raise wait times
for veterans like myself I still get my
health care at the VA it will raise wait
times for everybody else
how many wait times be worse than what
they've been at the VA where people died
waiting for care though they're pretty
bad let me tell you the bars pretty
yellow but if he does this it'll get
worse and and it's already bad enough
but the other thing is when he does
things like cut the state department
budget by 30 percent some of the
strongest opposition to that is from the
military when I get both sides of the
aisle because if the State Department
isn't there to do its job we're going to
pick up the slack what right after the
invasion I was an infantry officer where
at the invasion I was running a TV show
because there was no plan for the
occupation the State Department didn't
show
up and so they were assigning
lieutenants to go run the water
department one to run the police
department I was assigned to work with
the Iraqi immediate now the Marine Corps
at the time actually thought a free
press was good for democracy that's a
good lesson for the administration as
well but that you might have you run the
TV and or and bacon is in this one
station I had I don't know Riley's
looking for a what did you know what
would you think of Trump accidentally he
so it's so funny the way the Republicans
talk about our military I'm they'd like
these two ridiculous thoughts in their
in their head like one we could kick
anybody's ass and also were horribly
depleted I notice he mistakenly said
like he was talking to some interviewer
and he said you know we're very powerful
very powerful somehow we're very
powerful I mean kicking his ass but we
also need more money for this depleted
shell of a self that we are this is that
this is the president who praised Saddam
Hussein during the campaign who said
that he knew more about Isis and the
generals and he's the person he can
wieder later to one he's saying
graduated dictators what the [ __ ] did
you make of that he was called erna one
when he wanted you congratulations
ripple on dictator what a grip here if I
hear you're the broader issue also is
that this is an administration that is
not necessarily taking certain key
American values into consideration like
certain country human rights track
records and that sort of shifts a
broader global moral compass into a
direction that a lot of people are not
necessarily comfortable with when
America does something the rest of the
world listens whether or not they
support the United States to date and
this may be difficult for some people to
believe Syrians despite the fact that
they feel that they have largely been
betrayed by the United States still
fundamentally believe in America and
what America is meant to stand for when
America speaks when an American voice
speaks people listen when that voice
gives a little bit of hope people listen
they want to cling to that they want to
cling to this image of America there's
also that when I was in Lebanon in Iraq
last month talking to Syrians but also
to people in those countries they all
know about the refugee ban
it's it's a small world these days they
hear the message of Eros road
they're not gonna will be allowed in
here and I'm afraid that is a propaganda
gift to people who would do damage to
the country absolutely in it hurt our
troops yeah because you can't work with
those critical Muslim allies in fighting
terrorism you can't get the intelligence
service or psa's and the translators I
mean this is something this is something
that I mean just to put aside the
Constitution and American values for a
second just sort of minor things just
looking at national security the Muslim
ban to use the president's term for it
is terrible for our national security
para bajar and also it doesn't work
because as we've seen so many of the
attacks are from people who are already
citizens they're already here it's in
here it's not F it's not the airport
refugees have the strictest vetting of
any traveler to the United States so
actually if you're a terrorist you'd be
pretty stupid to go through the refugee
channel right okay is the DNC tour of
America headlined by Chairman I didn't
realize though is there a DNC tour of
America going on sounds like an awesome
comic headlined by Chairman Tom Perez we
had him on those shows being in the
season and Bernie Sanders a good
strategy for for Democrats I'm not I'm
going to take that laughs as an
indication that it is not what does the
panel expect from Barack Obama when he
starts to speak in public again as he
will do next month apparently he is
coming back
[Music]
it in your constitutional system he
can't set himself up as the leader of
the opposition here no but I tell you
what globally the center-left is in
trouble and globally Barack Obama is in
a position to convene to lead thinking
to actually support the renewal of
credible but also radical center-left
politics and that is something doesn't
fit him into a constitutional difficulty
but there are millions of people around
the world who want to see serious
progressive politics rebuilt and if you
think look we've got elections in France
on Sunday the Socialist Party has gone
nowhere they've actually got a strong
candidate now who's running as a
centrist Emmanuel macron my goodness
he's got to win because all three other
candidates if you look at what they're
saying about Russia if you look at what
they're saying about the transatlantic
relationship you'd be worried yeah
funny well I think that Obama still very
important voice for the Democratic Party
and I've been a useful one but I think
the party has to get around the specters
of these hundred-year-old
you know Maxine Waters and Nancy
Pelosi's and Harry Reid's that are
haunting the party's nightmare for hours
and identify the younger the Tim Ryan's
was elbowed out by Nancy floats because
she wanted to stay in charge but David
the Johno salaries 100% no it's get off
the stage I I completely okay if they're
going to continue insisting that the
party elders we're running the show
instead of empowering these younger
people no blood right like we're looking
at more
I'm spending a lot of guys you know
particularly Smarties a veteran Battle
of Little Bighorn Korea for where we're
going in this I'm spending a lot of time
recruiting it that's people to run yeah
you know especially if you have on and
we've got to get them especially on
windy seats that are tough seats to win
back and I get a look at Colin and I you
know Democrats too nice okay I get nasty
but little bit that will get vision
little bit because these these people
the debt the Republicans are like you
know what if they're gonna bring a knife
to a gunfight great because we'll shut
[ __ ] shoot them in the head and the
Democrats you mean look at the way all
all the whole election Trump was like
it's rigged it's rigged it's rigged as
soon as he wins oh it's good
and Hillary calls him up before the Sun
comes up you won by Obama has him to the
White House than exit you think they
would have done that if Hillary had won
no they'd be in the street still talking
about how the election was rigged they
cheap that how they win they see they're
seated they seated at the Supreme Court
to get a Supreme Court guy on there they
cheated a [ __ ] turtlehead mix
McConnell not one argued he he ran
circles around the Democrats and they
got a guy on the Supreme Court's going
to be there forever and he doesn't
belong there but look daddy fair there
are there look there are Democrats who
say I get a little be attending to this
by cheating and scamming and lying and I
don't think that's what we should do
I think we should have a real plan we
should have a vision for the country we
should talk about how everybody should
be involved in the new economy not just
the people on the coast how we need
people in middle america to thrive to to
start new businesses to have jobs yeah
belly
we need to these middle america okay and
kick them in the balls a little bit all
right thank you very much everybody
the earth great again
[Music]
[Applause]